– Das gibt’s doch gar nicht!
Ich arbeite doch nicht rund um die Uhr,
um am Ende nur die Hälfte meines
Gehalts zu bekommen!
Die spinnen doch!
Oh, sorry.
– Kein Problem.
Ich kenne das.
Nach Abzug der Steuer
und der Versicherungen
bleibt vom Bruttogehalt nicht so viel übrig.
Soll ich mal schauen, ob alles stimmt?
– Mhm.
Also, das hier sind die Abzüge
für die Einkommenssteuer.
Das hier ist die Krankenversicherung,
die Rentenversicherung
und die Arbeitslosenversicherung.
Und die Kirchensteuer.
– Was, die Kirchensteuer?
– Mhm.
– Aber ich bin doch schon vor Jahren
aus der Kirche ausgetreten.
– Also, wenn du ausgetreten bist,
dann …
musst du auch keine
Kirchensteuer bezahlen.
Ruf mal an und frage nach.
– Danke, mach ich.
Ist das die neue Website
für deinen Fahrradladen?
– Ja.
– Cool! Darf ich?
– Die Website hat schon viel verändert.
Seit sie online ist, hab
ich fast doppelt so viele Kunden.
– Im Ernst?
– Mhm. Das Problem ist: Ich
schaffe das nicht mehr alleine.
Ich brauche Hilfe im Laden
und in der Werkstatt,
um die Kunden nicht
mehr zu verlieren.
– Warum guckst du mich so an?
Was hast du vor?
Ich will dir einen
Vorschlag machen.
– Hm.